[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have top brass
really sure three key issues quite what
do you guys doing here and you should be
going that way what the dicks trimming
your face don't do it so you don't have
sorry love sorry street food
we shouldn't realize where you guys
going here of something is one line our
charts show that some people like it
better when you sit at a desk and do
nothing
come on how are we supposed to start a
half again so forgive you can't have
assassin without spinning twice bad but
thankfully you'll be distracted when I
point out that the flashes in this movie
that just needs to be said again all
right who would have known that a person
bent on taking over the world would
actually try and rule the world
oh good
I know you mail me Rin with how to fake
an obese wrong I am katana my sword
holds the enemy's souls that I capture
with the souls of that catcher come on
get in there man come on come on let's
call it dog
good now hold you got me now do you not
me do you not mean it I'm gonna buckle
[Music]
I'm a dinosaur so there's that what
about you die hablo we haven't gotten
your backstory dial oh sorry
and then I knew it and I was like you're
a lot dude I am boy sure I'm feeling
hopeless in there yeah it's not like we
listened not like we left you are you
ever get yours in none of you was
shocked by that we're bad guys how many
yeah we're bad yeah laughs really the
accent just just comes in waves
sure I'm feeling hopeless in here yeah
it's not like we live here we gonna pee
so bad all right super villains by
definition are the most motivated people
in the world I'm not giving in to not
just writing it all right fine the same
we are going to white guilt now you
happy yeah that's more like it
can you give him back my land while
you're at it for the fans
[Applause]
oh yeah what can we say except your well
girl must be part yeah
[Music]
okay